comme pour dire merde aux terroristes
ambiance musicale festive et estivale ce
matin dans les rues de dijon habitants
commerçants et touristes se croisent
comme d'habitude sur le marché même si
chacun en tête l'horrible attentat de
l'animé à nice sa première chose que
j'ai entendue ce matin à six heures j'ai
allumé la radio mais c'est affreux on
fait telle un 14 juillet mais c'est oui
j'ai des enfants je sais j'ai des amis
et d'ailleurs même j'ai des amis à nice
je sais pas j'ai pas de nouvelles mais
c'est inquiétant c'est très inquiétant
même s'avance à reims qui font l'état
d'urgence va être prolongée des mesures
ont été annoncées dès cette nuit par le
président de la république et tout le
monde est partagée entre la nécessité de
ne rien céder face au terrorisme et la
nécessité d'être vigilant même là
aujourd'hui voyez je suis en marché avec
le petit mais bon on va on va prendre
nos gardes
vous êtes vigilant ah oui je suis
vigilante face à un camion on peut pas
faire grand chose
après je sais pas ou alors il faut
complètement fermé la rue avec des
plaques de béton n'en finit pas quoi ces
volumes le 1er mai 16 je suis désolé
mais bon la vie continue regarder ya il
faut mettre une note d'optimisme malgré
tout dans ce monde avec la belle musique
à bon marché après le soleil
françois hollande a décrété trois jours
de deuil national à partir de demain
mais dans la capitale régionale dès ce
matin les drapeaux tricolores du grand
dijon ont été mis en berne